did you like about Sabonis up top he's
an elite pastor can really make plays or
support us knifing through the defense
right now not traditional like modern
big men both trying to play with really
two bigs it's a bonus along with Myles
Turner to the next level to be an elite
NBA player two minutes to go in the
first half of the first-ever game being
played in India has sabonis with a nice
drop step in a reverse teen points had
14 rebounds averaged 17 at 16 a year ago
events had nice scoop
[Applause]
sabonis shoots it and scores beating the
shot block loss against Detroit that's
knocked away
Pacers loose ball it's Sumner great job
let me tell you why it's a great job
because sapone this is the one that
popped the ball free front lock is down
on the shot clock
sabonis oh nice spin move then a really
good job he was initially the person the
Pacers were trying to go to second jump
is really quickly he's just not as thick
attacking hey there you go that's what
he did just attack him
and Simonis pounds it down how to read
the action you'll see right there
standing in the lane ladies and
gentlemen down to Georgia and the
monsters just goals and he moves him in
the chest and just clear space see how
the Macmillan's merges the the lineups
because not a lot of storing off the
bench here of late nets Justin holiday
with a nice basket cut
good job with the Pacers to gank rebound
around Tristan Thompson comes fast
there it is you could see it coming
brother bit finish and into the third
assist without the creek
mr. bonus it's a post against love
he just on the bench with 11 points uh
bonuses come back in him back count the
basket and a foul on a terrific pass
from the girl who started to feel the
good scream the team's there makes the
big difference in return tends to come
on the back side Bob he had an eighth of
seventeen to Baja
[Applause]
running warrant not just to score but to
find his teammate
zoom in society but this is the one
thing that he can do it that's where
he's got to be Commodus batons a in turn
are creating all kinds of problems for
the next
[Music]
[Applause]
when you go to work Sabonis got it
fill god and that was a good break for
the face because that was a late fan
great hands by lamb-lamb gets in there
missed it but followed by simona he's
all the soul I couldn't play dude turns
the court rocks layout pop set free
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's taken away the Pacers get the
turnover water to the basket with a left
hand is a good defensive player but you
gotta thought sorry to Sabonis and see
what he can do in there sabonis backing
on Gibson puts on the rules it's a
bullish has the Pacers on the board it
was seven points in five minutes come
off the bench provided energy for the
snakes groups of bonus
[Applause]
see what he breeds comes in a fate
Macmillan wanted it where can you make a
ploy and get an easy basket for your
teammate guy if that path wasn't ever
gonna it had no chance to get to anakena
swatted by sabonis Pacers bigs
protecting the rim here in the third
better shot getting better quality shots
I mean great recognition here and you
see Dotson come over late to try to get
to the block but McConnell heads-up play
gets it to the top Dotson comes over
those inside runs into Turner throws it
away tipped by Turner savolta's has it a
fourth
Clippers turnover Sabonis takes it
coast-to-coast it's going for 81 pieces
- there's Aaron holidays play and coming
to the middle Genzo who is top ten in
steals
McDermott got back great job for bonuses
you could see it coming one Stephen chin
so couldn't control it does not have a
lead change in the first quarter that's
a bonus from Brogdon it read quickly
seeing the help by Lopez come delivered
to the Sabonis who puts it on the glass
and gets fouled recognition by Brogdon
up the help so bone is strong enough to
finish
reuses at screen Ibaka comes back in
he's a threat for three-point range and
Sabonis blocks the shot great job he's
got eight and the Pacers lead is 11 yes
because he paid a basket now they're
worried about McDermott
delivers the Sabonis he got him on that
would impede that he but belted that
lesson will is this the sticky
Oh
TJ Ward no one is weighted to winning
that this 21 first half points
[Applause]
I'll be as a team shooting 37% they have
not shot below 40 percent this year what
a bass
[Applause]
are guarded by Harris has a pretty good
size advantage on Harris bears has
quickness great pass we talked about the
big man at the center of the game is a
17
just sent five
Acer's 11 assists on their 13 and that's
a block by sabonis is a good job in
getting there because we look at a part
trying to get to the rim on a 17-2 to
run they outscored philadelphia 38:16 of
the second and put it away
sabonis down with authority they says
basketball that is best open man gets
the ball you play with power and
strength big fella what's the right
thing to do you get it in the middle
that's been the story all night Pacers
get this rebound with Turner
it looks like India is gonna come up
short as some bonus schools and a basket
away a three of getting it down to a
one-possession game
Doug it's used the timeout they lead by
six he's down there guarding sabonis and
sabonis goes to work spins will aloft
and the Pacers on the boom and a nice
job getting himself to that right
shoulder but the guards had been
forwards to the to the point that JJ
were making have their responsibilities
but inside you closer to the rim you got
to get it as well I'm looking forward to
these three and a half weeks I was
getting ready to go out here perform for
Jersey playing with these guys on the
floor thanks to Victor Oladipo Pacers
trailed by five
MCS ninth most impatient to history when
you take a look at his numbers they were
really good
here's the bonus back in the basket I
mean turn the corners see it's open
[Applause]
[Applause]
so Simona cisterna - of to the Pacers of
any injuries and that's what you're
seeing with this Denver team the other
thing that they're switching everything
three in the corner no food Simonis
counted the foul it's 13 rebounds hey
she's gonna break you he gets fouled
here and then he went up with the you
got it there he is bonus came on the
other side miles has the mismatch nom
very good job this was a very good read
NASA bonus crossing over against shy
rich hold just spun him like a top who
kept it that's why I said tacking
couldn't wait to get out of there you
got five seconds on the shot clock
basket and a foul sub bonus after
missing two free throws he was patient
he's back at the scores bench so he must
have been back at the locker room
sabonis to steal he got his head up to
get his head off that's all he had to do
was get his head up
again through syphilis against Robinson
and a chance for Indiana to get into a
ten-point game but it doesn't point down
at the post position you can it's a good
call Horace rocked in the rebound
[Applause]
or the money sabonis out a hit you'll
see I mean he tries to file it and some
bonus makes the play there well that's a
foul every day all day every day unlike
some other teams they will not quit
splits the defense and Aaron Holliday is
there with a
pants of the cup now Sabonis is going to
drive right at porzingis oh and he just
pounds it down
he's having a hard time getting a big
set some bonus spins against porzingis
and de Montes another move you'll take
in at the end the day the box court does
not say back for sabonis pulling in his
way inside for the bucket
inside thus opponents got a mismatch
against Lowrey
land launching got it again the Raptors
appear to be putting another one in the
win column saponin
[Applause]
on the foul on an adobe turn this thing
around for the Pacers what did I tell
you about using big words like that but
great string Bob man
[Music]
[Applause]
and now
why first off I suppose he does not know
balance 435 threes a game and the Pacers
have given up a lot of threes of late
all what a pass no this is business damn
luncheon early but all the Depot has got
a nice job here we're getting 14 and all
the depot climbs in to get the rebound
stuff with the prince where he belongs
on the ground no-look pass great cut now
that's a little bit more rhythm there
before they make that call that was
called as you get into three knocks
great by Simone and soon it could help
us a bonus
now McDermott for three God and faith
Simona's double but Phil's hit with the
right hand
really good job abusing that offhand
Chris patience sighs is that your mercy
and you're trying to go down the lead
the pastor Ariza is in the fingertips
and out all the people the other way in
Ocala panic finger roll it up in
[Applause]
McConnell with a great feed and refused
to screaming roll and what do you do
fans here at the AT&T Center had a
chance to visit with some of those that
our pacer spans from Indianapolis who
now make their home and that's a steal
by sabonis here in Texas at that point
the guards have to do a better job of
the wings have to do a better job and
making good decisions so you don't get a
power kind of people under that yellow
away picked Oladipo being aggressive if
he can get those kind of things going
nice little ball fake defense up on the
baseline good recognition there by
Sabonis otherwise it can't read the
basket
I mean it was going good easy we've been
possibly another time out here's
McConnell with a basket there's only 20
points on the board now Boston may not
get dirty all the time but you younger
beaten hit the loo
you get 30 on the court and sabonis went
six so I get in 20 and 22 points in the
quarter you get from Meccano is his
recognition of where the opportunities
are going to the back defense down and
deliver the ball some problems who comes
hard to the way of a mentor can't
recover